>> Sean: HI.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
IN 11 DAYS, A MAJOR CHOICE
ELECTION FOR THE COUNTRY AND
TONIGHT WE'LL BRING YOU THE VERY
LATEST.
WE'LL HAVE POLLING, ANALYSIS AND
REACTION.
J.D. VANCE FROM OHIO WILL JOIN
US.
TED BUDD FROM NORTH CAROLINA
WILL BE HERE.
BILL HEMMER WILL BE AT THE
HANNITY HEMMER BIG BORE AND
WE'LL HAVE THE VERY LATEST
DETAILS ON THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA FELON THAT ATALKED
PAUL PELOSI WITH A HAMMER.
WE BEGIN WITH THE STATE OF PANIC
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY ARE NOW PETRIFIED BY THE
VERY REAL POSSIBILITY THAT
DEMOCRATS COULD LOSE THE HOUSE
AND LOSE THE SENATE, NOT TO
MENTION MULTIPLE MAJOR
GUBERNATORIAL RACES ACROSS THIS
GREAT COUNTRY OF OURS.
THIS WEEKEND, BARACK OBAMA,
BERNIE SANDERS, FIRST LADY JILL
BIDEN ARE HITTING THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL HARD IN A DESPERATE
ATTEMPT TO SALVAGE SOME OF THESE
RACES.
BUT NOT JOE BIDEN.
THE PRESIDENT IS JUST NOT UP TO
THE TASK.
IT'S MORE THAN HE CAN HANDLE AT
THIS POINT IN HIS LIFE, SO HE
WILL SPEND THE WEEKEND IN
DELAWARE WITH HIS GRANDDAUGHTER.
SO MUCH FOR NEEDED REST AND
RELAXATION.
AFTER ALL, IT WAS A BUSY WEEK
FOR JOE.
PUBLIC EVENTS ALMOST EVERY DAY.
NEEDLESS TO SAY, THE STRUGGLE
WAS VERY REAL.
YESTERDAY, FOR EXAMPLE, BIDEN
SEEMED TO THINK THAT HE'S
INHERITED $5 A GALLON GAS PRICES
AND YOU THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
SHOULD BE THANKING HIM FOR
COMING TO THE RESCUE.
HE SAID IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> TODAY THE MOST COMMON PRICE
OF GAS IN AMERICA IS $3.39.
DOWN FROM OVER $5 WHEN I TOOK
OFFICE.
WE NEED TO KEEP MAKING THAT
PROGRESS.
>> Sean: SO IS JOE LYING OR
MAYBE HE DOESN'T HAVE A CLUE.
THE COST OF A GALLON OF GAS WAS
$2.39 A GALLON.
IT'S MORE THAN DOUBLE THAT IN
MOST PARTS OF THE COUNTRY.
EVEN THE VERY LIBERAL
SNOPES.COM.
THEY SAID BIDEN FALLY CLAIMED
GAS PRICES WERE $5 A GALLON WHEN
HE TOOK OFFICE.
AS OF LATE OCTOBER, GAS PRICES
WERE $3.39, WHICH WAS ALSO
FALSE.
AS WE SPEAK, THE U.S. IS NOW
BARRELLING HEAD FIRST IN TO WHAT
WILL BE A DEBILITATING DIESEL
SHORTAGE JUST IN TIME FOR
CHRISTMAS AND JOE BIDEN SEEMS TO
HAVE NO IDEA.
DOES ANYONE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION KNOW WHAT IS
GOING ON HERE?
DOES ANYONE SEEM TO CARE?
BECAUSE ALMOST EVERY SINGLE
THING YOU BUY AND EVERY STORE
YOU GO TO IS TRANSPORTED BY A
DIESEL POWERED 18-WHEELER, THIS
IS A MAJOR CRISIS WAITING TO
HAPPEN.
IS ANYONE SURPRISED?
THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE, THEY HAVE
NOW MANGLED ONE CRISIS AFTER
ANOTHER.
AFGHANISTAN, THE SUPPLY CHAIN
CRISIS, THE BABY FORMULA CRISIS.
ALL OF THAT TRANSITORY INFLATION
AT A 40-YEAR HIGH.
THEY TOLD US ONLY TEMPORARY.
HERE WE ARE NINE MONTHS LATER.
THE CRISIS AT OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER THAT GETS WORSE EVERY
MONTH.
THE VIOLENT CRIME CRISIS AND
SMALL TOWNS AND BIG CITIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND OF
COURSE, THEIR IDIOTIC SUPPORT
FOR DEFUND.
WHO CAN FORGET THE OIL AND GAS
CRISIS WITH BIDEN HUMILIATED ON
THE WORLD STAGE BY SAUDI ARABIA
WHILE DRAINING AMERICA'S
STRATEGIC PETROLEUM RESERVE ONLY
FOR POLITICAL GAIN.
THAT WILL STOP THE DAY AFTER
ELECTION DAY.
JOE BIDEN AND HIS FELLOW
DEMOCRATS WANT TO BE REWARDED ON
ELECTION DAY.
THAT WOULD BE DELUSIONAL.
IN 11 DAYS, YOU THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE HAVE THIS CRITICAL
OPPORTUNITY TO SEND ALL OF THEM
A RESOUNDING MESSAGE AT THE
BALLOT BOX.
ANY NEW GREEN DEAL CLIMA